[Musique]
je vais vous confier un secret que vous
ne resterez pas ce soir ici est toujours
de ma route je le trouvais dans une
atmosphère du même genre que celle de la
libération
si vous saviez qu'elle confiance
la france révélée après l'immense
épreuves portent maintenant faire vous
charles de gaulle voulait de la foule ce
jour-là rétablir un lien brisé entre le
québec et sa mère patrie brizay deux
cents ans plus tôt quand la france avait
abandonné la nouvelle france futur
québec ou militaires anglais à la
recherche d'un symbole il a trouvé
peut-être une hyperbole quatre mots qui
allaient faire chavirer la foule et la
politique canadienne québec
[Applaudissements]
les bleus québec libre
ces quatre mots jetés du haut d'un
balcon par un politicien souvent
critiqué par ses alliés pour son côté
impétueux ont enthousiasmé une grande
partie du peuple québécois dans la folle
c'est le réveil captée par les micros de
radio canada
un étranger un gaulois venait de
reconnaître la résistance de ce petit
groupe d'irréductibles québécois est
temps que les politiciens du québec se
prononce cette question là maintenant ça
prenait un étranger pour le faire qu'est
ce que vous en pensez quand il a crié
vive le québec libre
c'est un effet psychologique pour la
foule parce que quand il a lancé vive le
québec la foule réagit beaucoup alors le
général a dit vive le québec libre je
pense qu'il pensait vraiment que ce que
disait ce point mopar tient à lège pense
que le mot a été bien réfléchie de sap
en face à nous à londres à quelques
avantages du canada va comprendre qu'il
ya les québécois ainsi qu elles veulent
vivre en français par la france en moins
de vingt quatre heures il ya mille
québec sur la carte remplie il était le
seul à voir la statue refaire il était
le seul à oser briser les rêves pour le
faire et il l'a fait
c'est extraordinaire le chef du parti
politique appelée rassemblement pour
l'indépendance nationale rcn pierre
bourgault se réjouissait de cet appui
inattendu à sa cause souverainiste
comment voulez vous qu'on ait des
aspirations comment voulez vous qu'on a
envie de se battre quand on le fait
depuis deux ans dans complet et compères
qui va être profondément colonisés et
des chats qui nous a fait crier vive le
général de gaulle parce que lui pour la
première fois en deux ans
il est venu là sur notre terre nous dire
en français ce qu'ils pensaient c'est le
premier qui a gagné est venu lui dire
l'enfant pas l affaire a été très mal
perçues au canada du premier ministre
canadien à l'époque au directeur du
quotidien le devoir à montréal claude
ryan un fédéraliste convaincu et je
pense qu aux yeux de l'opinion
internationale c'est un terroir quel
dernier mot et lui subi une perte de
prestige considérable parce qu'il est
obligé de partir plus vite qu'il ne
l'avait prévu
le but est raté presque complètement
monsieur de gaulle avait déclaré en
descendant dans son four lions dimanche
et rapports entre nos deux pays par
l'état ce moment un as du canada et de
la france ont tout faux c'est excellent
et je sais et j'espère qu'il en soit
toujours ainsi
là il a branché à ceux gravement les
rapports entre les deux pays et je
partagerai défini aucun vos mails
français a formulé aujourd'hui à ce
sujet le plus vite
le président de la france ça remettra de
nouveau aux canaux diplomatiques pour
rétablir les liens le mieux ce sera pour
le bien des deux pays pour le
développement des relations
le président français se permettait une
rare ingérence dans les affaires
intérieures du canada encore aujourd'hui
la nature potentiellement être visées du
discours de charles de gaulle alimente
les discussions
il n'était pas prévu d'abord qu'il
s'adresse à la foule à montréal cet
après midi là il se serait laissé gagner
par l'ambiance dit on la journaliste de
radio-canada marie-eve line michel
rencontrés en 2002 pierre-louis mme
allen qui avait organisé la venue du
président charles de gaulle au québec en
ça fait des années tombe pas de cette
question
jamais personne n'a donné une idée au
général de gaulle vous donnez l'occasion
d'une chose que importante qu'il faut
dire c'est de gaulle avait dans l'esprit
ça depuis toujours depuis très longtemps
je veux vous donner l'exemple
j'ai fait des recherches là dessus en
1940 quand de gaulle est arrivé à
londres
il a fait le fameux discours l'appel du
18 juin qui tantôt les livres d'histoire
quelques jours après il a fait afficher
dans londres la france a perdu une
bataille elle n'a pas perdu la guerre
à ce moment là à savoir le 1er août 1940
il a fait à la bbc un discours destiné
acquis aux canadiens français et ce
discours est magnifique il dit vous êtes
un exemple pour nous parce qu'en rameaux
de la souche française s'est si bien
développé là-bas où l'avait planté là
bas en amérique où l'avait plante est ce
que ça nous donne la certitude que la
france c'est 2 le 1er août 40 ô ô comble
des valeurs de l'histoire de france
comme les bals du temps de prendre
depuis jeanne d'arc on n'avait rien vu
d'aussi bas la france après ses grandes
misères ce qu'il évoquait après la
grande victoire
eh bien elle sera grâce à vous elle sera
à vouloir et elle saura croire ça montre
combien il avait ça dans l'esprit et de
gaulle et est convaincu d'indépendance
du québec depuis déjà quelques années au
moment où il fait le voyage c'est un
message d'autodétermination que le
général livres et qu'il livre ailleurs
dans le monde également il encourage les
peuples qu'ils ne sont pas indépendants
qui sont sous le joug soviétique
contrôlé dans les énergies les encourage
à se prendre en main et à devenir
indépendant l'historien québécois
frédéric bastien premièrement il ya un
problème entre les canadiens français
afin une blessure il ya une coupure et
il faut faire quelque chose pour
rétablir les ponts entre la france et le
québec d'une part d'autre part il ya un
problème entre les canadiens français et
les canadiens anglais et de gros c'est
le parent de la décolonisation lors de
son retour aux affaires c'est la guerre
d'algérie c'est de gaulle est appelée à
liquider lempire français il comprend
que les peuples du monde
aspect en l'indépendance il en vient
concevoir des canadiens français comme
étant justement faisant partie de cette
longue liste de peuples qui se sentent
opprimés et qui aspire à l'indépendance
et à travers ce prisme qu'il va voir la
situation et avec dès son jeune âge j'ai
eu un intérêt pour le canada français
durant la guerre par exemple il y avait
beaucoup de canadiens en grande bretagne
donc beaucoup de québécois
et quand de gaulle en croisés et par
exemple ainsi conseiller quelqu'un dans
son entourage fais une remarque par la
suite sur l'accent les canadiens
français est alors de gaulle val est
tout de suite allé
reprendre en disant vous savez si peu si
peu à travers son attitude il y avait
des signes évidents qui montrait une
sympathie pour le canada français un
intérêt pour le canada français et il
avait même appelé les canadiens français
en 1940 à venir aider la france qui
faisait face évidemment opéré de la
deuxième guerre mondiale pour faire un
peu de lumière sur ce moment sombre de
la politique canadienne
ou encore ce moment illuminé de la
politique québécoise 2 annotations du
général sont significatives sur un
télégramme reçu d'ottawa est datée du 22
décembre 1967 dont quelques mois après
son grand discours de gaulle écrit en
marge il faut soutenir le québec sur un
autre télégramme daté du 10 avril 1968
il affirme nous n'avons aucune
concession à faire ni même aucune
habilité à faire à monsieur trudeau
alors premier ministre du canada qui est
l'adversaire de la chose française au
canada
un reportage de radio canada
international